I'm working out to have my ideal body
type and you know what type that is none
of your [ __ ] business
Liz Oh straight up drops the mic on all
the body shamers namaste have a great
day here's what went down on Tuesday the
Grammy winner kept it real like really
real on Tik Tok posting a new video
about her fitness routine and her
self-love hey so I've been working out
consistently for the last five years and
it may come as a surprise to some of
y'all that I'm not working out to have
your ideal body type I'm working out to
have my ideal body type and you know
what type that is none of your [ __ ]
business oh she said it and she made
sure everyone knew exactly who she was
talking to captioning the clip quote if
you're not a fat Shamer keep scrolling
okay now that all the fat shamers are
here I am beautiful I am strong I do my
job and I stay on my job so next time
you want to come to somebody and judge
them whether they drink kale smoothies
or eat McDonald's or work out or not
work out how about you look at your own
[ __ ] self and worry about your own
damn body because health is not just
determined on what you look like on the
outside health is also what happens on
the inside and a lot of y'all need to do
a skin cleanse for your insides and mic
drop
turns out I'm on Japan damn Beach even
when I'm crying
crazy yeah she just took a DNA test and
turns out she 100% wasn't done the truth
hurts singer also posted a clip of a dad
and his two sons reading comments from
an internet troll saying that the young
boy needed to work out or he'd end up
like Liz oh your son needs to go in at
least exercise or he's going to be the
next Liz oh the 32 year old shared her
reaction to the sweet clip grinning
ear-to-ear as for her caption Liz L
wrote quote oh you mean the next million
dollar dealing cover of Vogue having
three-time Grammy Award winning icon
actress activist with a perfect app I'm
feeling good in 2019
Liz o told et she's focused on spreading
good vibes to her massive fanbase and
she hopes her music will be a form of
therapy for them just like it has been
for her all these years I read this on
Twitter
Liz o gives us a pep rally for our self
esteem at every performance the way you
have embraced yourself and this energy
and the way you uplift everyone else is
so magical is that who you've been your
whole life is this on purpose like make
me feel so happy haha well it's
definitely i'm intentional i want to
feel good like I um when I was younger I
had a friend who was always helping me
out with self-care and he would be like
you know you're gonna take some time to
meditate you got to eat bagels with
cream cheese you got to chill and also
you're so good at this you're so good at
being happy and he was like well I'm
only good at being happy because I was
so sad I needed the most and you know
it's the same with me like I need this
music to be my therapy because I have
been so low and I refuse to you know
live life like that anymore
[Music]